Hello Stanford community, I'm Rob Siegel.
>> I'm Lisa de Simone
>> My name is Ed Battista.
>> I'm Britney Nicole's
>> Ashley Martin here.
>> My name is Chun Woo Choi.
>> I'm Kristen Wheeler.
>> Hello, my name is Becky Lester.
>> I'm Rod.
>> I'm I'm Zack Tormala.
>> Hi folks, this is Sarah Singer.
>> All the way here from my
house on Stanford campus.
>> You can see it's incredibly quiet.
We miss you all.
>> Welcome to my home office, I mean,
my Stanford virtual teaching studio.
Milo is going to be a part of the classes.
>> This is my home assistant, Mr. Bongo.
>> Josie, My trusted coated retriever,
[LAUGH] is very happy to
have me around all day.
>> We know these are really
uncertain times.
>> I feel more connected to those
are who especially living in
different parts of the world.
>> I know it's been difficult,
from the canceled plans,
to the new anxieties, to the new
inability to be around people you love.
>> At times like these, I try to focus on
things in life that I am grateful for.
>> These are certainly going to
be trying times for all of us.
We can all use a little
extra tending right now.
>> One major silver lining for me in this
period has been that I'm getting to spend
a lot more time with the family.
>> What it makes me realize is that,
though Stanford is here,
Stanford is actually where you all are.
It's online at the moment.
>> But then, I'm amazed at how
people have bonded together.
>> It's been an opportunity
to take a step back.
>> This quarter will be what we make it.
>> It's really been pretty
miraculous the way people have
come together to make it all happen.
>> To appreciate each other,
because at the end of the day,
we are all in this together.
And I have no doubt that we
are going to come out stronger and
more unified than ever before.
>> In these times I think about how we
can make the best out of the situations.
>> While we welcome you back,
we know these are not times that you would
normally script for a spring
quarter of the 2020 academic year.
>> So let's do our best.
>> Thank you for
all you are and will be doing.
I can't wait to see you
online this quarter.
More importantly, I can't wait to
see you in person in the future.
>> I certainly hope we see
each other up close and
in person soon.
[MUSIC]